you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with a Nancy Fielder editor-in-chief of
national world cities and Jake Wallace
Simon's editor of the Jewish Chronicle
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
tax Wars is the headline on the front
page of the Metro after Labor kicked off
its Party Conference by promising to
scrap the Tory tax cuts
that story also features on the front
page of the Guardian which highlights
akiristama's pledge to reinstate the 45p
tax rate for the highest earners
the mirror leads with comments from
footballer Gary Neville who says the
government's tax cuts are immoral
the tax cut theme continues on the front
page of the Ft which focuses on
suggestions the chancellor could slash
taxes even further
The Daily Mail labels those plans for
even more tax cuts as courses boost for
families
the express front page is also focused
on the economy and Liz truss's promise
of growth
the times headline reads pay pain for
workers as public sector squeezed after
the government abandoned plans for a new
spending review
and finally on the front page of the
star New Revelations in the Q gate Saga
involving Holly Willoughby and Philip
Schofield
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and I'm joined tonight by Nancy Fielder
and Jake Wallace Simons welcome to both
of you let's start with the guardian and
the quote there from Zakir starmer I
will reinstate 45p tax to back Public
Services uh so that is one tax that he
would reinstate but not uh the other not
the the one penny Jake
yeah this is interesting I mean it's
totally predictable of course that kirst
armor would latch on to this abolishment
at the highest rate of of tax uh because
it suits um you know his his base and
his agenda and don't forget the the
highest rate of tax was introduced by
Gordon Brown just just before he left
office as a sort of trap for the Tories
tempting them to roll it back and then
face the uh public Roth as a result of
doing so but I think that it's important
to see this in in the overall context of
the figures the highest rate of tax
raises about two billion pounds a year
for the uh for the tax takings for the
government
um and overall the government's tax
takings is 900 billion pounds a year uh
if kirstana seeks to direct this 2
billion pounds towards the NHS the NHS
itself costs about 150 billion so it's a
very these are very small numbers that
we're talking about and set against this
let's not forget that the top one
percent of earners pay about 28 roughly
of of our of our taxes and so you can
see why this is you know an easy goal
for Kia stama but when you look at the
figures it's quite a small amount and
from the point of view of the government
um it's worth sending a signal that
Britain is open for business is no
longer in the thrall of the uh politics
of envy and seeking to attract uh High
net worth individuals to Britain to help
get the economy moving so you can see
that makes sense from from Labor's point
of view to make this an argument but
actually within the overall text of the
figures doesn't necessarily raise very
much money at all
but do you agree with that uh Nancy that
it actually doesn't raise very much
money
I'm not sure I do to be honest and I'm a
little bit fed up with the sort of
politics of Envy phrase we're not
talking about Envy because everybody
wants to be a millionaire we're talking
about very basic things that people
can't afford to do we're talking about
our country that is Rife with food Mass
because people can't afford to buy
enough food to feed the families
everybody is worried about how bills are
going up it's it's still going to get
worse and worse and yet we all we're
seeing from the government is more
support for the people who have already
got the most money but it is quite
refreshing now I mean we are back away
from all the middle ground of
conservative and labor policies they're
a little bit hard to pick between but
this is this is really a conservative
government doing exactly what you would
expect in the labor party fighting back
again with exactly what you would expect
so I think this is what the labor party
should do to aim for its voters and the
working people who are being given a
really rough ride all the way along to
be honest
and people saying that this mini budget
was anything but uh there were so many
um changes but the chancellor promising
that there's there's more to come when
we look at the Daily Mail Jake
that's right I mean this was far from a
mini budget this was a this was an
earthquake in British politics and in
British history I mean as Nancy pointed
out this is a huge departure from the
vying for the center ground that we've
seen over the last you know 20 30 years
really in in politics since Blair uh
onwards
um but she also makes a very fair point
about you know the poorest people in
society and the the the support that
they need and I guess what the Tories
are trying to do now under Liz trust is
prioritize growth at all costs this sort
of Kamikaze drive for growth
um every policy is geared towards
creating growth based upon a very potent
ideology of tax cuts to create economic
stimulus but also supply side reform and
it's important that you know people on
Lower incomes uh people who aren't
working and so forth are not caught in
the crossfire as it were but they also
receive benefits and boosts that they
need in this time of a huge cost of
living crisis and this story on the
front of the mail uh goes some way
towards suggesting that there might be
some help for um for working families
with for example one person staying at
home to look after the children they may
benefit from tax cuts targeted at them
as well so this is a broad a very broad
agenda a hugely broad agenda that's
being put forward by the new trust
Administration and um you know we can
all just cross our fingers and hope that
it works because our backside onto the
wall in this country
uh Nancy do you believe the chancellor
when he says that uh he is there to help
families struggling with with the cost
of living
um he said we've only been here 19 days
I want to see over the next year people
retain more of their income because I
believe that's the British people that
it's British people that are going to
drive this economy so he's saying that
he is actually helping those that you're
talking of
but he is saying that but actually there
isn't a massive amount of detail this is
looking forward to things that may come
but the two things that are mentioned is
um the changes around child benefit
which impacts families who are earning
over 50 000 pounds and helping families
where one of the parents stays at home
and doesn't work now most of the people
who are struggling the parents are
absolutely out working because they
couldn't possibly afford to have
somebody at home and they're unlikely to
be getting enough here to be able to
just quit their jobs and actually 50 000
pounds of the impacted on the child
benefit is a really good strong salary
compared to most of people talking about
here so I'm not convinced that what he's
aiming for here is any different than
what he's been doing already I don't
think it will help the people who need
it most and I think it's great to be
looking at families but I don't see any
details here that will help the families
who are struggling the most I'm afraid
and Jake what can we read into the
markets on the announcement of the the
mini budget the 37 year low for the
pound against the dollar Tory back
benches and potentially cabinet
ministers also getting the Jitters a
little bit as regards to to the economy
in the pound
absolutely I mean the markets are
spooked let's make no bones about that
they are totally spooked and uh some of
the government supporters have been
arguing that that's because
um the you know the government's actions
have been talked down so much by The
Establishment you know the liberal media
and and the kind of financial Elites and
so on and so forth but there's no two
ways about it the plan that the pound
has plunged and the markets are spooked
and I think that the markets would have
taken a lot of this they would have
taken the reverse as the National
Insurance rise to corporation tax you
know to kind of steady the ship they
would have taken the the great boost uh
in terms of lowering our Energy payments
they would have taken that because
that's kind of in line with what other
European countries are doing but it's
really the ideologically motivated tax
cuts which has spooked the markets which
nobody expected to come and that's
really what's created the Havoc
um on the markets overall and caused the
the plan the pound to plunge now
personally I sort of share those sorts
of politics that wishes to see a low tax
high growth economy but even I feel a
little bit nervous about the the speed
at which this is happening and the uh
and the pace at which it's taking place
so like I said you know we're all
rooting for for the government in a way
you know and for the country even people
disagree with the government I think is
hoping that this will succeed and return
us to growth and get us out of this cost
of living crisis
okay for the moment thank you both Jake
and uh Nancy blue there for the moment
we're going to take a break
coming up put more papers including this
story on the front of the financial
times Italy election polls point to
Maloney Victory as the country elects
its most right-wing government since
Mussolini
stay with us on that
if you're watching the Press preview
still with me Nancy Fielder and Jake
Wallace Simons let's take a look at the
Ft they're looking at the Italian
election their front page exit polls
suggesting that Georgia Maloney is uh
Victorious and will be with her
Coalition
um far-right Coalition that it will be
Jake your assessment
yes I mean it looks like Maloney will
win and I think there is a lot of
Hysteria about her calling her far right
but if you look at her policies they are
more like a traditional conservative
rather than far right she looks to
people like Roger scrutin in Britain and
even Tolkien she's very Christian in
terms of the culture wars she speaks
very strongly against things like gay
adoption that sort of thing well she
describes herself as center right
doesn't she but but elements of the
Coalition would be far right
thinking of salvini yes and also the
other important point is that she leads
a party that has its roots in
Mussolini's Italy and so that
immediately casts a Paul over it even if
she herself has disavowed the
anti-Semitism and the other uh fascist
and uh you know principles that
Mussolini espouse in this she's similar
to some something like perhaps the
Sweden Democrats in Sweden who've just
entered a coalition as well who come
from a not you know far-right Nazi past
but are saying they've broken with that
tradition so I think that you know there
are a lot of reasons why people are are
worried about her this isn't just empty
these aren't just empty concerns but at
the same time it's for everyone to judge
whether those contexts are are worth
condemning her for or whether one to
judge her buyer her policies and what
she actually says and it's quite
nerve-wracking time really for Europe I
think yes I mean many commentators
saying that Italy is heading towards the
most right-wing government since World
War II Nancy
yes absolutely and she it does feel like
she has shifted to make herself more
electable rather than actually changing
her beliefs so it is going to be really
interesting how it plays out and whether
she has just sort of made herself more
acceptable to more people
um rather than changing her original
thoughts um and quite have a lot of them
are very very right wing it's
particularly worrying around Ukraine
um that I've seen quotes kind of saying
oh the only person who will be
celebrating this well the first person
we're celebrating this um is in Russia
and we'll be putting so this is going to
put huge strain
um on all sorts of relationships with
posture and it is a really worrying time
she's the first woman to have been
elected in this job in Italy but I think
there are greater concerts as we wait
and see how it unrolls
final look at the telegraph just got
time to fit this story and then this is
the the United States uh warning of the
consequences if Vladimir Putin does use
nuclear weapons
um very disturbing distressing in fact
Jake
yes I just wanted to correct that point
that Maloney has been distinct as being
as giving supports to Ukraine rather
than like some of the competitors were
quite pro-putin but just that that aside
um absolutely Putin gave a not very
heavily veiled nuclear threat once again
to the West last week and now it's the
turn of the Americans to respond Jake
Sullivan revealing that he's given in no
uncertain terms some warnings about
catastrophic consequences to the
Russians at a high level were nuclear
weapons to be used I think this is
something which Putin must take
seriously and hopefully will take
seriously because you know he would
almost certainly if he were to use
nuclear and it would be a tactical
Battlefield nuclear weapon it wouldn't
be a you know a missile launched at New
York or London and the consequences he
would face would be from an
overwhelmingly stronger United States
let alone the other Democratic allies
that stand uh in NATO and this war has
shown just how relatively people Russia
is by comparison to the west and so you
know the the balance of power remains
very firmly in the West's favor and I
think that he would do well to to
recognize that and we would do well to
be confident in that although without
downplaying the the horrible threat that
he's that he's aired last week yeah and
just to read uh Jake Sullivan's quote if
Russia crosses this line there will be
catastrophic consequences the United
States will respond decisively Jake and
Nancy for the moment thank you so much
we'll see you in the next hour